even before nadia comes into view
struggling to find her feet in this
hellscape you can feel the rawness of
her shock and sorrow
and it was without warning that grief
came to the people in this street in the
small town of back moods
as she approaches the bodies her husband
also draws into view
the couple heard about the russian
airstrike and came to identify their
family members
[Music]
they are soon confirming what they
didn't want to be true
on the ground in front of them covered
simply are their relatives luda and
volodymyr
oh
everyone is traumatized here
damaged by a conflict they didn't want
and are powerless to stop
[Music]
the street has been decimated by the
attack debris blasted across the
neighborhoods
this was a massive bomb
that landed here
in fact survivors have told me that when
it struck
it felt like the world was ending
the explosion could be felt all across
the town
now we were staying nearby and the
building that we were in shook us awake
that happened at about four o'clock this
morning
but as you can see massive destruction
to people's homes and their lives
vasily shows me his house he doesn't
know where he's going to live now he
tells me with his wife and three
children
[Music]
with its military advanced stalling
russia's bombing campaign across eastern
ukraine is
intensifying and as this woman salvages
what she can from the kitchen of her
family home she tells me there were no
weapons or soldiers nearby
this is just one street in one town
paying the price of the kremlin's
aggression
but with people across the country
bracing themselves for more attacks
there will be many more lives destroyed
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine